or army officers in Burkina Faso have
announced the overthrow of military
leader Paul Henry demeber Captain
Ibrahim troyore has been declared the
new head of the West African country on
Friday explosions and heavy gunfire were
reported near the presidential Palace in
the capital wagadugu it's Burkina faso's
second coup in just nine months
army officers addressed a nation the
national television broadcast and adults
over who's now in charge the military
leaders had overthrown their own
Lieutenant turned president and promised
to tackle the volatile security
situation
conscious of our historical
responsibility the Patriotic movement
for Safeguard and restoration hereby
commits all fighting forces to refocus
on security and the restoration of the
Integrity of our territory we reassure
the International Community that Burkina
Faso will continue to respect its
International commitments including
human rights
prior to the announcement protesters
took to the streets of the capital of
wagadugu to support the removal of
President Paul Ari damiba the now
ex-president came to power in a previous
coup d'etat in January
but his promises didn't convince the
Burkina Bay
we want change
truly fundamental change a change that
will bring peace to Burkina fazo even if
it takes 10 coups we will find the right
solution
land and air borders as well as a
nighttime curfew but more measures will
be needed to restore peace
many in Burkina Faso are frustrated with
the government's inability to stem
islamist violence in the North in the
latest deadly attack 11 soldiers were
killed on Monday by jihadists in soon
Province while escorting a civilian
Convoy
so far almost 2 million people have been
internally displaced by the violence
Friday's overthrows the eighth
successful coup since Burkina Faso
gained independence from France in 1960.
well journalist Henry Wilkins joins us
from wagadugu good day to you what do we
know about those taking over who exactly
is in charge right now
so it seems the person who's behind this
coup is named captain Ibrahim Trailway
uh he's an obscure figure we don't know
very much about him at this stage other
than the statement that was made on
National Television last night where
they said that the government had been
dissolved and the um uh former president
amoeba has have been posed now they said
in the statements um on television the
the reasons for their taking power was
that amoeba had made a lot of Errors
particularly with regards to security uh
since coming to power back in January
they cited political Misadventures on
his Parts as well
um so yeah it seems that these uh is a
faction of the military that's been
unhappy with his uh the way things have
been going under under him for the last
uh nine months right Henry what do we
know about the ousted presidents
whereabouts
we know very little about his
whereabouts at the moment there's been a
lot of misinformation a lot of rumors
online uh some have said that his house
was surrounded by uh by troops yesterday
but at this stage we we have no idea
where um we're the former president of
the neighbor is
[Music]
this of course is the second coup in
Burkina Faso in just nine months what's
behind the instability that we're seeing
insecurity so Burkina Faso has been in a
conflict with uh militant groups linked
to Islamic States in our paida since
2015.
um the the previous Democratic president
was uh was ousted in a military coup uh
back in January as as we've said
um the justification for that who again
was the the the democratic government
had not been doing a good job on
security and been unable to reign in
sort of daily and near daily attacks
that are happening
um in Burkina Faso and the loss of
territory I mean the the country is uh
only controls about 60 percent of uh of
the country's territory at this stage so
uh but you know the basis for this for
the coup that happened back in January
was that uh was the the military
government would come in and sort out
this insecurity that really have
happened they've continued to lose
territory the attacks have continued and
in the short term there was a large
attack a uh on a on a convoy of basic
supplies
um going to a town in the north on on
Monday which seems to have sort of
triggered uh this latest wave of
distance
um in the short term
journalist Henry Wilkins in Burkina Faso
thanks so much
thank you